greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy sell
stocks ETFs options and kryptos or
Commission free okay they strive to make
Financial Services work for everybody
not just the wealthy non-intimidating
way for stock market newcomers to invest
for the first time with true confidence
what I'm gonna do is this Robin Hood is
giving the church family a free stock
like Apple for its print they listen to
me a free stock like Apple for the
sprint to help build your portfolio sign
up at church dot Robin Hood calm again
that's church dot Robin Hood dot-com
listen let me explain something to you
right everybody thinks you're smart
you're thinking only smart do me a favor
if you want to know what you're smart is
you got to go to zip recruiter to hire
the right person
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them
before you
it's a powerful matching technology that
scans thousands of resumes identifies
people with the right skills education
and experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply so you get
qualified candidates quickly so what I'm
gonna do is this right now the church
family can try zip recruiter for free at
this exclusive web address you ready sip
recruiter calm slash Church again that
zip recruited dot-com slash Church again
that zip recruiter calm slash Church
listen if you're gonna do something do
it the smart way hiring was hiring with
zipper Karuna that's smart I also like
to introduce to the church my bookie
listen tomorrow night's Thursday night
tonight it's turns on their football and
you're sitting there again you don't
know what to do who to bet listen
whether you're an expert or a rookie you
should be betting at my bookie if you
didn't type of guy likes to make a bet
about a little one a lot like playing
the numbers on the roulette you can
create a big parlay tomorrow night
that's three picks that's usually three
teams you could do three 10 picks you
can pick a college football team
two picks on the pro you over and under
the pros and if you hit all three you
could turn 100 hours into sectionals
all right why sit on the sidelines when
it's time to get paid go to my bookie
right now log in and double your money
you're Joey what do you mean yeah use
promo code Church CH you are CH and
you'll get your first deposit matched
100% Joey what are you talking about
100% if you put in a hundred don't give
you a hundred you play you win you get
paid that's what my bookie does alright
so go to my bookie right now and log in
with promo code Church CH you are CH and
double you abduct your initial deposit
by a hundred percent kick this for
[ __ ] melee I still remember
this album coming out but that's how old
I am I like waiting around cuz it has
been 3 years to stay released around his
kid died and really nobody knew the
future Led Zeppelin Physical Graffiti
was a [ __ ] masterpiece but when this
came out
you took we took meetings for this
because no matter how good it was there
was always a Beatle fan that said don't
make you bash I was talking about my cat
last night walking around wide yeah and
Greg this only happened in my house once
before when we first moved here there
must have been a cat that was pregnant a
neighbor and one day I'm watching TV and
I'm Aaron what the [ __ ] and Fidel was
swollen Oh Fidel was the nicest cat in
the world and he always said he looked
like a [ __ ] raccoon oh no and he was
about to attack the other one and I had
to get sit down Fidel was hissing at me
I had never seen that before and then
one time the Donald Superbad have beef
since day one they've had beef since day
one the Dow is always superior to
Superbad but Superman's a scrap you
can't you gotta watch something bet
that's the type of cat that you'll beat
him up and when you're [ __ ] shaking
hands with your friends you come back
and bust me he's black and white nobody
really likes him in the neighborhood
nobody
super bad when we first moved up the
corner one day Superman was fighting
Harry and he beat Harry up how he ran
away and super badly you know I'm
feeling my oats right now he looked over
on the couch and the doll was sitting at
the top of the couch and my wife had
just put the laundry basket down and she
had taken the laundry out Superman looks
at fidella you know what now while I'm
[ __ ] you up I might as well [ __ ] you
up - he jumps on the chair he jumps on
the couch and he heads towards Fidel
Fidel's got him by 10 12 pounds mm-hmm
Superman scrappy to the death super bad
jumps on sit down
Fidel's not ready for it they're
fighting they land in the laundry basket
the laundry basket flips over it's like
a fight I open it up they both break
away like what the [ __ ] - cat Center one
can't leave my side that really yeah my
cat saw a war and last night was one of
the scariest - yes - des I got six now
oh I'm down to six there was there was
ten at one time I was Demi had lost like
the one man was Fidel [ __ ] and somebody
else then I gained one when I moved to
this neighborhood
she's my bodyguard all right she's loyal
to me even the owner said the cat and
you you know the cat was walking up the
stairs scratching on the door and my
other cats were hiss at it wait it
wasn't lost no the owner gravity I read
the differently I rent a little par to
bedroom apartment yeah Wow house and
they had an outdoor cat friends his cat
I would come home from any food don't
come and go they can't would come out of
a [ __ ] bush and bring me a mouse a
[ __ ] rat called the cat was tough as
nails you know you know my brother found
an atom you know he loves cats he found
an outdoor cat and he said that that cat
first of all just goes through the
screen like if you the screens out but
she just cuts a hole on the screen comes
in
but with
outdoor animals oh yeah what kills them
and eats them next to my brother like
like she's proud up to the table yeah no
just when my brother sleeping he'll wake
up because he hears the cat eating a
dead and like a present yeah they bring
it so loyal that bringing you that price
[ __ ] crazy when you live with a cat
you live with a [ __ ] killer
a killer yeah after midnight once
darkness sets in when you're around the
couple cats you could feel it they have
a certain energy at night it's very
tough to describe living with cats and
dogs is to day and I love them both yeah
if it was up to me I have 20 of each do
you remember I used to have this huge
Saint Bernard my god sure but he looked
like Beethoven you know only kids and
everybody thought he's gonna be super
friendly but he had been hitting that by
a van in the head when he was like a
puppy and it turned him super mean yeah
so you remember people used to run up to
this a hundred and forty pound dog like
hey it's Beethoven and I ain't you
something's gonna slow slow him down
slow him down he came so close to biting
off so many little kids faces it was
[ __ ] crazy then he had a dent in his
head so whatever side of the head that
he got hit on changed his like emotions
entirely how do you deal with that on
yeah it was [ __ ] he almost bit off my
cousin Scott's nuts in my apartment he
hated him and I could tell he hated him
but because I was in the apartment he
wouldn't do anything but I could tell he
was he put his head down and just kind
of oh I want to bite the [ __ ] out of you
right and we were moving me out of that
apartment and Scott and I were in the
apartment together and I we were about
to you know walk out and I was like hey
I'm gonna go get the elevator and as I
turned the corner out of the front door
I thought oh that's a bad idea and as I
was turning back in his name was bud bud
was lunging for Scott's not
Jing it was like he was like it was hard
it was hard a little bit by a dog yeah a
little bit on there nothing crazy oh my
my sister has this little dog and I went
home and she said yeah come on over and
and just you know when the dog sees you
it's a little hyper or whatever but you
know just ignore it I was like aren't I
so I walk in and dogs barking all around
and I just ignored it I wouldn't sat on
the couch and the thing came up and sat
on the couch next to me and just kind of
stared at me for a second mm-hmm and I
was like hey buddy you know and okay and
then I slowly started to get up and it
bit the inside of my thigh and last on
so if I pulled my leg up and it was
hanging for a second and it was all was
rough you know for a tetanus shot all of
that [ __ ] I don't think I did you're so
close to do yeah I think I had one
I think I'd had well I'm really careful
with mercy and dogs yeah as I was
traumatized young I got bit in the face
by a German Shepherd Oh the Bronx iced
and they kept telling me not to look in
the mirror don't look at yourself in the
mirror and I remember just having cotton
taking the cotton off and seeing a patch
of my face missin going Jesus Christ and
not faint thing you know crying yeah I
was scared I didn't know but then I went
on a rampage we're getting bit by dogs
because of the fear yeah you can't have
fear around dogs so I would see a dog
get fearful they would bite me so I went
on I got a bit like four times after
that you have to what's that fake it
till you make it type of attitude yeah
and I said you really have to believe in
your heart that you're not scared of
dogs no more and I stopped getting bit
huh but I had such a fear that they
would they wouldn't leave like a dog
would see me two blocks away and then
attack me because that's how much my
fear was towards him no wha and then one
day I had like let the fear go from
inside I'm like the hatch what it feels
like not to be scared and they never
mess to me again
that's crazy by the time I was doing a
burglary
I've had a ball [ __ ] a week and then I
had a burglary turned on me that [ __ ]
dude you feed him
WAPA shame a dog a whopper bites they
love it they'd spit on the tomato did
you show up with a whopper the day of
the burglary no see yeah but how do you
not show up with the whopper that's most
that time we built the bomb parently not
apparently not you made a very good
point yeah you care to bring the whopper
and take the [ __ ] wampum that's my
that's my slogan for life you got to
bring the whopper everyday that's where
we hope inside myself every day
Bobby Weinstein said to gotta bring the
whopper everyday he rapidly in different
states and [ __ ] that poor bastard they
got a pipe in India can you rape
somebody somebody haven't seen one in a
while a picture of them at a supermarket
he's reading no no no they just took a
picture of them at a supermarket reading
one of the [ __ ] mags just like
catching up reading what a Hollywood
yeah I'm one of the mags one of the
gossip mags
I got Gareth these like looking at this
dog what I didn't even come other tits
and a mouth she's such a [ __ ] liar no
he aim at her [ __ ] why is he saying
that I can't what a face he's something
because he's I believe he's getting
accused by 25 women I believe 25 one
it's a it's a hiline 22 other women are
just jumping on the bandwagon or
something I you know what I wouldn't be
surprised if you gave me a super high
number of actual cases I would not be
surprised if you think about all the
access he had to these girls on a daily
basis on a
daily basis he had access to these women
and women who aren't even famous now who
we don't know about who aren't for sure
are coming forward because people are
gonna be like means like you know we
they're gonna be dragged through so much
[ __ ] so man i-i-i don't know i saw a
video yeah you see that video of him
where some woman was pitching him some
idea or something and she had a her
camera on her laptop and she's just
sitting there very businesslike and
she's showing him what we could do this
and we can brand your thing here in this
movie here and he's just Darren at her
the whole time and then he says yeah
yeah yeah yeah we'll do that so so
you're gonna be gonna be nice to me
you know nice and it's like within like
a minute so I'm sitting down yes so much
access if you gave me if you said the
number actually is in the triple digits
I'd be like he was in this business 20
years yeah I [ __ ] believe that you
know you take your dick out 10 times a
day those are the same you know if you
can make it the 10 spots of one day that
would be tremendous
like he left nobody knows what kind of
car you got actually because people
looking for you with a gun people
looking for you with like a bag yeah
somebody yelling we just walk into Whole
Foods in the granola he's like three
house mom yeah with yoga pants on you
take out your dick give it a minute
oh man you gotta count to 30 seconds it
was like practical jokers that's the
show we got a pitch Josh bull hey guys
we gotta find something hey got you dick
for three minutes of the [ __ ]
supermarket and see a little Sukkot this
your TV class I'll place that right now
I would bet you this because in college
we used to take out our nuts at a bar
and we would call it hanging brains and
we would see who could hang brains along
as well nobody [ __ ] notices you know
who notices oh they're dudes
oh they're dudes will come up to you and
go hey man you're nuts you're out yeah
I'm like yeah dude I [ __ ] know I know
my nuts are oh oh they're dudes but like
no every time somebody said something us
it was a guy who was like hey man you're
nuts right you know I was tailing
awesome logistically
high/low like four men that can press
charges oh yeah yeah so poor that I
wouldn't get a little ripped dude why
fix it you would sit there and show you
my balls
I still remember one day Jason Rogan
with my job and he was losing his mind
like nobody had ever chased him he's a
Joey I swear I'm gonna hate you
well he wouldn't turn around he kept
running because my balls in my hand I
rub them on you he could definitely take
that I knew he didn't wear underwear any
at holes in it sometimes yeah I got a
kid but you know please I love a hole
you give all your pants you ain't [ __ ] I
saw this look at these ready count the
holes this is all from marijuana one
these are all my because I smoke pot
while I take a [ __ ] I have a back
bathroom everybody complains that they
have a hard time taking this [ __ ] I have
a back bathroom in the office I open the
door I could open the door into my
backyard so in the mornings after I have
my coffee a piece of nicotine gum I give
it like 20 minutes I sit out there I
feel that pipe up when I start hitting
and when you call this [ __ ] flies out of
the air so the other day
they're taking a [ __ ] with my pants down
with my things like yeah me undies on I
got sweatpants on and dog pee though I
want pink white one of those yeah and
then ash flew right out a fool right
between my mind I could see them in
these going on fire a piece of shits
coming out of my head you know you're
not to push no more like are you going
to smoke it comes right out like [ __ ]
yogurt at med cheese comes right out
weed this way you don't have to wipe
your ass I went to the bathroom one day
yeah I don't will you take a [ __ ] that's
disrespect that's disrespectful
yeah so I'm sitting there look at the
trees you Elementary School behind my
house I hear kids playing on the tree
it's nice so I'm sitting there one day
well what else can I be doing while I'm
sitting here I got two birds one stone I
got the weed right there yeah so I take
the weed out ice melts and when I push
the first time nothing you caught just
every time you call piss ease you hit a
little pieces fly out of your I can lose
some weight steady
dude I I thought I was sitting next to
you on my plane ride from LA to Boston
last week this dude with lightened up
the ball I light him up on fire I'm like
those tolerant now so before I fly I
have a look shake can I just to make
sure I make my stay on the plane can I
tell you this dude so first of all he
was trying to be sly he he would do that
little shift and right when he did the
shift you would get hit with you
yeah and and you know it was him just
because of like there's a certain
freshness proximity gives you you know
what I mean I know your time you know
warp to it you can tell how much it's
been diluted by the time I guess you but
if you're on full blast you know you're
right next to the person right dance at
this so so he hits me right and the
first one I'm like you know I'm gonna
respect that okay we respect Lube by the
third one I actually it was so bad I
said out loud
come on right he's looking at his iPad
he's got his headphones in he never
looks at me
look he's gassing me the whole flight
word about to 10th time and I'm not
kidding when I tell you I this is how
drastic is you know the pillows I have I
have them over my face so just my eyes
are already and when he farts and I
smell it I put the pillow over my face
and I turn and I look at him do you know
this [ __ ] never let me look to
my way now what's like a [ __ ] window
yes mistake number one
he never take the way we're so bad at
the window because then you're trapped
in the hail in that fart the fan ah the
air-conditioned is at your feet
that's where the favor you blow you
smoke of a pen on the complain what
happens to the smoke go like this blow
it at a angle down and you'll see you go
right into the floor so you're inhaling
even if I Monroe I'm across from you and
I'm blasting you're inhaling if I have
to fart brakes same way he's supposed to
like it's supposed to now when I got on
the plane I make sure he's got your
phones on if I see everybody with your
phones on I'm going off I even pivot the
hips up do you
oh yeah cuz I know how to pivot the hips
yeah my goal is to make a bouncer and
I'm like this so it bounces off the
screen right into your face so you sit
down game a pause like a George Gervin
you can understand but people don't
understand this if you take an early
flight you're in danger because that
means 20 people got on the plane without
their morning [ __ ] and they had a call
fee and then JetBlue were opposites I'm
drinking double expresso yeah
you understand me double doubles going
to the menu last week huh can I read you
the menu of Judge Lumia can I really T
last week let me read your last week's
27 years of flying has done is you know
how to fart on a screen this is les
right
this is Sundays menu you ready all right
it opened up with a pea ricotta pesto
dip with crostinis I passed out I have a
cos annex and I smoked the joint of that
dirty bazooka uh-huh and I woke up and
there was [ __ ] a little trail of dip
with a bunch of Italian bread and cheese
it was peas and then I had a kale Cobb
salad Atrisco citrus salad seven grain
risotto pan-seared halibut and a citrus
braised pork that's how you live on
[ __ ] um look at the what it was oh my
god I forgot that she was there and look
what wasn't on my Jesus I forgot he said
that to me
I took that [ __ ] the morning I said it's
like a brown carrot sticking out that's
beautiful that's a and when you flush it
it breaks in half and then I guess and
they choke each other like I'm going
down first no I'm going to that yeah it
looks like something they would fight
with on Game of Thrones yeah just right
yeah I think so imagine seeing that at
7:00 in the morning oh my god I hit like
2 or 3 people with that email and they
were like what the [ __ ] Tom Segura
always gets all the bigger the pieces
Tom Segura he never moves probably loves
you never post these on Twitter be
nothing it's endless you'll get [ __ ]
from all over the world for days is that
true yeah you take a picture of [ __ ] and
put it on Twitter and tell people like a
joke you know doesn't RB somebody takes
a [ __ ] for the next 5 years you're gonna
open up your Twitter there's a picture
but if you have a friend that enjoys
those pictures yeah if you have a friend
that enjoys those pages yeah Tom Segura
the bigger the [ __ ] he gets the first
picture 19 inches he gets the first bits
like a fit like you and you measure a
fit you can hit Thompson or up for a job
anything he'll take him an hour to get
back to you hit him with a piece of [ __ ]
right back all Jesus right back to it
wake somebody service it okay do you get
do your pictures of [ __ ] okay nobody can
throw heat like that no that's Adam to
compete what I do is see that's after
three days like I was telling Lee when I
go on the road my [ __ ] knows it
doesn't want to [ __ ] up the bathroom at
the hotel so it just drops off a little
turds from time you don't [ __ ] at the
back at the hotel
my [ __ ] don't like it but once I get
off the plane and I hit the 405 that's
when your [ __ ] starts telling you
what's that song here we come by the
time I hit the 101 and my [ __ ] spots
of Laurel Canyon exit in two miles you
hit that and when I'm making that left
around Laurel km hope there's not a
homeless lady my asshole's on fire
I put the luggage down I run right to
the bathroom and
I mean whether that's the first thing I
do all that land I the bathrooms of the
hotel I love but they're always by the
door so yeah that's the whole room so
next thing you know you are the room
service to the poor guy from Haiti has
to come in ya mind themself of his
country I was in he's been here for two
years got a great cut he's working
midnight room service he needs to smell
this [ __ ] again I thought you'd like
that it's like grenade or something know
if I'm [ __ ] my hotel right class
[Laughter]
destroy the lobby you'd rather sit in
the lobby than in your room ya know I
gotta sit in that room for 12 hours
can't you shut the door even if you shut
the door there's a little Joey well yeah
I just had peered pan-seared [ __ ]
crostini a lot of those hotels don't
have fancy though so no no I just took
me believe like nothing I get a cup of
quality excuse me where's the nearest
robust getting rich was their bathroom
just throw that in a second Emily really
you go right there to that hallway and
blast it out when you're walking out the
janitors walking in and you look at them
[Laughter]
like five in the morning do you go
downstairs no I would never wake up at
five to have to do that but if I have
time like if I'm civilized and I don't
have to go to the bathroom like if I'm
getting anxiety I'll shoot down stairs
and go in the hallway I don't want it in
my bathroom in my room then their room
stinks for two [ __ ] days I know what
comes out of my ass no ventilation no
open windows because the the fart smell
goes away ah
but you always have that Center smell
like if you ever cut a piece of [ __ ] if
you have a Boston anything like swallow
ring and you have to go cut a piece of
[ __ ] in half just smell that now that in
the middle is brutal no my kid my kid
too swallowed a little metal ball once
and I had to the duty of making sure
that you know that it came out at some
point so yeah
did you go in with a spoon oh you going
with a spoon and a paper plate and it's
[ __ ] disgust but what did he poop in
like a bucket yeah I had a little like a
colander thing that he could yeah take
it dump it and how many did you have to
go through before you found your I mean
you know what the well they really gold
mine it was only about four or five get
a spaghetti strainer yeah got a
spaghetti
yeah put the [ __ ] in there no and then
hit the spaghetti strainer but in the
kitchen yeah you kid ruined the whole
[ __ ] plantation so for you had to go
through it four times yeah yeah and then
you fight and you've never been so happy
to find something in your treasure you
never gonna have to do that again yeah
Wow yeah and and does he remind you that
you did that
ever no how old was he probably four I
had to remind my dad yeah I think I
would you remember when that time when
you had to go through my [ __ ] I think
it's Cisco all that stuff Oh what do you
do with this spoon after oh you use it
for coffee they got to throw it out you
throw it away it's a plastic spoon okay
yeah if I did I got the washer give it
to you so you get nice TAS in your mouth
so you can finally like to eat ass
something something to bring you that
you don't eat ass after you eat the soup
you'll go Jesus the supervillains in a
spool woulda spits let that bad
publicity ass what's the difference I
told you I told you to me the [ __ ] is
like the bodies of vanilla extract it
smells and tastes completely different
you know what I mean like it you know
how vanilla extract you're like oh that
smells nice and you taste it you're like
that's bitter
and you smell the [ __ ] and you're
like that kind of smells like [ __ ] but
you've tasted you're like it doesn't
really taste like it though you know
what I mean
I think I think this is just everyone
who's done it once everyone
wants me to do it now because it was so
terrible you have to be gentle your
tongue no no I'm just telling you
offered to put a clan together [ __ ]
he will lick it off with a line of coke
are you kidding me what this will numb
tongue I don't want to numb tongue you I
mean that's quite an offer and for
that's a good story for it to be your
first time I don't want there to be any
time so I would really why is that weird
please don't get him started really
everyone was saying I have to do it it's
it's their [ __ ] up there I don't care
how you all those heroes all my heroes
you thought you think Charles Bronson it
has no pain from eating ass that's why
he always looks like a great man a TAS
they flip them over opened up that
[ __ ] stuck a finger in it those guys
don't eat the papers the best is when
you finger the [ __ ] for a while and
then you take your finger out of that
face rape but comes out and you take it
like a man you smell the as we like I
don't give a flower I got twins of coca
me I've done worse you know I'm saying
you just get that first fume of kidney
and [ __ ] coal and it smells like
everything live without the onions Greg
Garcia what's happening this is why I
just come listen the stories this is
crazy I love it not gonna ask you
something yeah because I'm just telling
the joking on stage lately and I don't
know if it had to do with you if my
memories [ __ ] up okay when we lived in
Seattle don't tell them that I got beat
up with the Umbrella I don't wanna hear
that [ __ ] again who whose idea who was
the promoter of that show the promoter
that show was the skinny we had gotten
drove up in the hearse the play he was
how he was talking about so he was that
he was a DJ and he used he used to
travel around a hearse and then he would
bring his stuff in in a coffin and he
what was the name of the night fetish
night fetish late okay and so they could
come in with any fetish they wanted and
then downstairs in the basement there
was that side room where they could do
extra weird [ __ ] but they had to pay an
extra $50 I think to get into that room
and so that was the room behind the bar
remember downstairs behind the bar where
the guy was putting like jumper cables
on his nipples yeah and that's the way
that's all I told this guy's story that
I went to a place when telling where the
guy was upside down and they were
sucking his dick and it was I remember
leaving then going that's tough to suck
a man's dick when they're upside down
because all the head to all the Bloods
in the head yeah and I remember going
like I went overlooked and the guy was
sucking like like his chief the sucked
in yeah went downstairs it was a chick
on a pool table one night no emotion
they had to tied up to every hole yeah
like and they weren't [ __ ] her or not
didn't share like a thing that would
have key on it the chastity [ __ ] ass
the belt and they would melt wax on and
she had like nipples on her ring and
this was your place yeah downstairs Loco
there was a that back room there was one
night where there was a glass table and
dudes would get under the glass table
and watch naked girls squat and and poop
and they would pay a ton of money so he
got me a job we got the guys paid a
tunnel I'd be up in the piece at this
place oh I don't know I'm upstairs
checking IDs but people are coming up
saying what's going on and I will go up
stash coming it worked the door for fine
this doesn't take a peek and let me tell
you something all those fetish things
it's like when you go to a nude beach
there's nobody in a nude beach that you
want to see in nude like when you hear
advertising for a nude beach do not go
there people that look like oh yeah
women that look like Tom Brady's wife
does not go to a nude beach now and when
you go to those [ __ ] fetish things
it's people who just there wasn't one
like the de lady that we saw that was
naked a [ __ ] was so [ __ ] ugly like a
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] ugly like if I
remember anything from that Club was the
one night when the chick was tired for
the pool table
and in your wildest dreams you couldn't
[ __ ] this chick but they were all like
they were all lovey-dovey it was the
scene where everybody wore the better
you were in in that yeah I remember that
[ __ ] real sex on HBO and they do like
not good look
he brought roast beef rough crowd the
woman had a gut like mom like that that
time I wasn't even got heavy yeah we had
a gut they were put they were put my
piercings with hooks ah so they would
pull on it from different direction but
do you remember the one thing I'll say
never a problem that night do you don't
I mean there was you were security [ __ ]
not really do you know what I mean like
no I don't know that was out of all the
nights that I had there there was never
a problem then you had an Asian thing
were you made that was you stole $1,000
but they they were drinking Dom Perignon
and he would come home and go his $50 I
stole a thousand they were paying
obscene prices free
I was like how much you want this bottle
of creme creme de menthe yeah and me
like $500 I mean you got $500 of creme
de menthe it was ridiculous yeah but we
had there was a lot of security that
night yeah those shootings and [ __ ] that
yeah I would come foon Billy Seattle
yeah it was rough it was rough and those
brothers ran it and that one dude who
owned the club partially owned it when I
first started was part of the Korean mob
in that was a that was real shady the
first six months or so that I worked
there until the Japanese got to go over
until Aki took over and he was a real
good dude
he just went he was he was a really good
dude he just wanted the reason that
place got shut down
memory got shut down because I was out
of town doing a gig and he decided to
throw a party at u-dub and and just put
posters up all ages it's not an all-ages
club i would kept telling him he was
like yeah but it won't be a problem I'm
like if you do this party we're gonna
get shut down and he was like no no that
won't be a problem because we'll make
sure they're not drinking I'm like how
you gonna do that
and sure enough before I got home he
called me they shut the place down I'm
like yeah
um because I had the sweetheart of a
deal man
yeah what did you do exactly I he gave
me ten percent off the top because he
was gonna close it down and remember I
kind of I was like hey dude
before you close it down give me three
months to try to turn it around and he
gave me three months and he was like
this is going way better than I thought
it would what's it gonna take
and he was like how about 10% and I
thought he meant alike whatever his
profits were it was - he gave me he
wasn't a great business guy he gave me
10% off the top and I was like that's
good and then I got to bartend any night
I want to do I got to hire my friends I
get to set up all I did everything yeah
he had a great lunch ah dude use that
Mexican guy could to make chocolate hit
mOLAISON boy so ah so good lunch at the
place yeah el Lobo Loco he let me rename
it and I would go on any of the oh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it is the woman tied to the pool
table during lunch that's a full night
yeah now a lunch lunch crowd yeah I
didn't play as well at lunch well they
also Alex Rodriguez his 21st birthday
yeah oh yeah yeah all right you know
women walking around with shots there
was also a nightmare where they had a
release party for the hairy old heroin
chick and I heard horrible stories that
she had guys shooting uh the Kurt
Cobain's wife oh yeah yeah yeah you
gotta remember this was downtown Seattle
and it was down the block from the bass
player from Soundgarden's box and
essential was essentially it was no no
no solo ball local had a parking lot
next to it and then you walk to the
corner and you cross the street
and if you walked 50 yards it was
somebody from Soundgarden on the bar on
that Street at that time so they were
all Soundgarden was never there but
people were always there yeah and then
if you walk the other way down the block
you hit the calmly underground yeah
which was my favorite Club of that
[ __ ] block and a half to the crown
the underground and I'm looking at you
and I have him
you could have gotten killed down oh
yeah you could have got me yeah is that
bad huh there was something about it
that you don't know what it was heroin
I'll never forget one but it was really
just there man
it was that that's where he just that
one three blocks action yeah was a skate
cuz I still remember you booked a club
on a Monday night one time after the
open mic right down on the corner yeah
and we walked that we were yelling at
two guys that were getting into a fight
like these guys were about to stablish
doesn't like a [ __ ] you they're like
[ __ ] you and they kept fighting him and
like the guy would stop him look at this
like I'm coming here it was crazy it was
it was it was one of the best times of
my life
yeah one of the best for how long were
you guys up there he was up there way
longer than I was 93 to 97 for me Wow
no no 94 to 97 I walked in 95 and I made
it to 97 okay yeah 97 I got arrested six
times and tweeze no wait Jacob was born
97 I made it to the end of 96 yeah cuz I
came in January 97 yeah Jacob was born
after that yeah yeah [ __ ] crazy yes
because what year did we meet 99 okay
all right yeah 99 you know what's funny
is I I so the first TV deal that I got
off of that one-man show thing he was
the writer
for it and he but he was being oh he was
being overseas yes some guy was
supervising supervising a guy named
Danny Jacobson was supervisor so I but
you know I I saved that I tell you I
saved that script yeah that you wrote
and I read it the other day and I was
like this is still [ __ ] funnier than
anything I've ever written in my entire
life like that yeah dude it it it's
still really fun weird fun that would
though yeah but Dana Jacobson was
bananas now he was not sweet they put
Joey they had this guy like yeah I
hadn't really done that much and so
they're like this guy's gonna oversee
you or whatever but the guy was [ __ ]
nuts
and and
you didn't know we didn't know what he
was doing big ego I remember he was
somewhere one night and I knew he was
connected to Josh and I thought to
myself Josh might have a problem with
this guy and I didn't meet him I didn't
shake his hand somebody just said that's
Danny Jacobson I might tell you is he
still around
yeah I think he did something recently
but I don't know some tabs I might tell
you something I don't think I've ever
told you might make you feel good yeah
so he handed the group that his script
it was way better than I think Danny
wanted your script to be this is me just
guessing and after he read the script
which we everybody on the team was like
this is a good [ __ ] script when Danny
Cohen said we don't need Gregg anymore
that's basically how that went
yeah and said we don't need Gregg
anymore and I was like we do actually
kind of need Greg this script is really
good and he was like yeah he convinced
me he was like nods and I was like I
think it is everybody thinks is really
good he's like I'm gonna write a better
script he went over his resume a couple
times which was at the time real good
yeah yeah so every day we go over to his
house I'm by the way he was the first
dude that I ever thought I can't believe
how much weed this guy smoked he had a
drawer full of joints and a drawer full
of just money he had a dude that he
can't that came over to type for us that
he called clack e but he didn't tell me
his real name he was like he's the
typewriter guy so he said his name's
clacking we never put a word to paper we
were there for maybe three hours he had
a huge screen TV he loved The
Honeymooners we watched a lot of
honeymooners smoked a lot of weed you
know nothing
he was like now and he was like no now
for but for the meeting with the network
we were at he was there was a script
promised and he was like Nora I'll bring
it'll be good I'll I'll get it to you
I'll be good good good good good I think
maybe a day before the meeting we're
going in he sends everybody a script and
I get the script for the first time cuz
I'm sitting around I think I'm waiting
for notes I'm just like I write I gave
my script to this dude I'm so show too
he'll give me notes soon I guess he's
taking too long to write it and then or
read it and then
on my doorstep there's a script and it
says written by him mm-hmm and then me
underneath them and I'm like with it and
I'm looking through it and I'm like this
is I this isn't anything that I wrote
yeah and it went to everybody Network
everybody it was okay we walk into the
meeting the next day now I will tell you
this so Danny had told me that Gregg
script was not that good and I knew that
Danny's script was completely different
than Gregg's so do you know what I mean
I was like well maybe the one that I
think is good is bad and the one that I
think is bad is good because they are
completely different if you don't I mean
we walk into the meeting the guy the
network guy standing he holds the script
above the table to me and Danny and my
manager I think drops it for effect BAM
and just looks at Danny goes I don't
[ __ ] get it at all
and Danny was like which part he was
like the whole thing he was like what
happened to that other script his
current and he and it was a [ __ ]
scramble it was a scramble but I was
sitting there watching what I thought
was because of how excited the network
was and this [ __ ] guy watching what I
thought was oh this has got a shot too
as the script was dropping that was
mimicking my career just oh I don't
[ __ ] get it at all I was like oh my
god and that was yeah that's crazy I
didn't know that part of it but um it
was yeah yeah what a crazy [ __ ]
business but I didn't know you got the
script I got it on my doorstep I think
they just maybe accidentally sent it to
me or maybe he was trying to gloat and
he was like you want to read a real
script yeah yeah yeah and I call I
called the network just picked the phone
call the network I said hey I just got a
script I don't I didn't write it so just
so you know I don't you know I don't
know what to tell you okay where'd you
go after you wrote that script well that
was a funny thing cuz that guy too while
we were working on Josh's show at one
point I had two pilots going on and
Josh's and another one and he said to me
oh you got another pilot Danny Jacobson
sent us
yeah and he goes it'll never go all
right well that was yesterday six years
so that's what I did right after the
Josh thing I did yes dear 416 who was
your boss on that one Danny Jake no no
it was just me me and I'd created it
with a guy named Alan Kirschenbaum so
it's just the two of us created the show
together so what were you said Daley
Jacobson well he was before this when I
was working with Josh he told me that
that yes dear he said it'll never get on
he just like in the middle and just for
no reason he just was like yeah yeah
that shows nothing what he had done
wasn't mad about you Roseanne that Oh
both of those yeah that's why he was so
hot and and he was for the story that I
was telling it was Roseanne was the
right tone that we were kind of going
for but you know what's funny about that
yes dear pilot I remember you sent it to
me and I got to read it and I remember
thinking to myself as I was reading this
scene this scene this scene is so funny
it could get a show made and it was that
scene with the Bayona baby at the end
yeah that's the only thing I've got that
show in the air yeah dude that scene I
wish I would sure I was laughing so
[ __ ] hard yeah but like it was
hysteric yeah but the whole the whole
script doesn't work today it's just too
easy to manipulate yeah you know video
and stuff like that so it's a bit where
a baby walks across water cuz these two
idiots they needed to splice the home
video and what have you and it's just a
visual gag but now where didn't work
yeah you just put a filter on anything
you do whatever and stuff but yeah they
were trying to get away with taking to
the baby to the casino right yeah yeah
something like that and so they had
video and they were just they tried to
replace it with something but they made
the baby when they showed the wives to
convince him that they weren't at the
casino they showed the video the baby
walking on water yeah which is domestic
which is a dead giveaway you know that
they but it's funnier when you see that
you grow up you know you grew up
wherever the [ __ ] Virginia Beach [ __ ]
you grew up watching stupid [ __ ] TV
shows
and now you believe the business have
twenty years you've controlled three or
four [ __ ] big-time shows like it's
nothing are you funny you think about
this [ __ ] you know it's not just being
out here he's been out here hitting
homeruns like you know and and and and
we've both been on some sets your sets
are different than different anyway
different but from the moment you get on
the set to the moment you leave the
people on your set are super friendly
yeah it's a good group I most haven't
been working we've been working together
yeah you know 10 15 years it's really
important to me that when I know
somebody and I go in that if the
director is friends of mine or somebody
important in that film is a friend of
mine I go doubly perfect prepared yeah
so the first time I booked my name is
Earl I knew my lines forwards backwards
I in there straight but with weed in my
bag and I still remember wearing
camouflage shorts but my name is earl
shoot was like an 11 and i had to go to
a meeting then when i was making a
little stupid joint karate videos knows
we're not stupid has her made i had to
go to some [ __ ] meaning a meaning
that was a pot company or something so i
war against all my beliefs cuz if you
look at any piece of my clothing there
was never a piece of clothing with a pot
anything on it uh-huh
I've never done that in my life I don't
like bought clothing I don't like
psychedelic clothing but for that reason
that shirt was so cool it was the first
original California sign they made of
reefer mmm-hmm and it was a yellow shirt
and it mixed with the camouflage shorts
with white sneakers you pimpin so I take
a shirt with me and I go I'll go to the
meeting with this wheat shirt on and
then on the drive up to my name is Earl
I'll switch t-shirts I was sold I'm
gonna give me money I got so caught up
with the video that I didn't realize
was walking with this weed t-shirt on
till I hit the first day there she goes
cool shirt right and all of a sudden I
want the trailer and I'm like what am I
gonna do shows and my wardrobe wasn't in
there so I wasn't walking around and
everybody started going crazy oh man
[ __ ] tremendous pool and within
minutes I smelled weed and I go I'm
gonna cool [ __ ] it's okay yeah you will
occasionally you also without a doubt
consistently best food on set there
whatever trucks you're doing and
whatever money you're spending you do
know I'm curious
oh so Sundra heads am a good big
different like good food on a set makes
it big damn good food on this set makes
it all worthwhile but it shows you like
that you that the person that you're
working for cares a little bit right
there they're putting a little extra
into it you're there so long yeah yeah
14900 you yeah only a few people will
give you cards when you shoot I'll give
you something him you know almost gave
me something that I cried I still have
it Dick Van Dyke oh yeah I shot one of
his lifetime movies and he gave me a
bottle of something why laughter chef
something with a little no thank you for
doing a hand-written that's the world
yeah it's great yeah yeah yeah what's 69
a day I played a bookie and I cried
every time I looked at up and he finally
came to me he goes why are you crying
did you have a death and I go no you
were the first guy I saw when I came
from Cuba on TV and I can't stop crying
he was like really it's great speak
Spanish by watching he's like really
English and he just became mad that his
son was working it's those little things
even when you work for hanamichi lay
that he sends you like a blanket
I still got my longus your blanket do
you [ __ ] yeah I take it to the beach all
the time yeah I got a guestbook towel
for you okay yeah a little blanket yeah
yeah
last night it's crazy how this thing
came along called the 100 day movie and
people really took advantage of that and
I'll never forget one night doing a
pilot for Astra a pilot for after that
was a hundred dollars a day I had two
scenes but I told him how to do it but I
want cash because my drug dealer and
what time is my call and what time am I
getting that cuz my drug dealer closes
it up there the first night and they had
nothing it had nothing what do you mean
they had nothing Happel oh yeah yeah
those granola bars the next one up ten
it was like the Taj Mahal because the
after guy was there and I told the guy
go big difference tonight he goes what
are you talking about I go last night
then this is a pizza shop they didn't
have a pizza and he go he gave me his
card and he goes from knowing you wanted
he set and they're missing it cuz I
started talking to the guy thinking he
was Joe Schmo yeah and the guy took a
liking for me goes here
take my card I work for after next time
you wanna set there's no food call me
[ __ ] immediately so I became the guy
the Whitey Bulger of movie that the
director just recently passed away good
guy oxies got him or whatever got him
good guy but I'll never forget like they
told me when I got the movie that I was
gonna work 21 days straight it's like
I'm cool with that
you know and the first day they're like
you know you pay for your own lunch you
got to go off the set
hmm and I just done spider-man 2 where
they did not give you lunch
but they gave you 25 a day and they
really did give you lunch yeah they
really did give you lunch
and I and after the second day I go can
I ask you that and there was nothing to
eat who can ask you that hasn't quite
like that
it started shooting on a Thursday so
Thursday and Friday they set this out
the line so I don't have to director I
go you really want us driving around if
you only have 21 days to shoot this and
he goes well that's the budget that we
have
so then we had to work Saturday and
Sunday I came in bro now let me tell you
something I'm shooting something on a
Sunday I'm taking a man or a woman away
from her family on a Sunday I'm gonna
make it a little special yeah I'm gonna
make it a little special yeah what I
usually do plus some you know as I am
and I'm gonna make it a short day I'm
gonna make this like that three take a
same day but yeah it's Sunday why are we
[ __ ] around I'll never get gone there
and at this time I was very quiet on
sets
I was a comic and I didn't like how
comics will have thon sets that they
were trying to steal the show so I
wanted to shut my mouth that there was
no trailers it was you know wasn't and
they had names of this movie at the time
but the main guy being the father and
the fighter that's how I met him okay he
lives right around the corner the father
in the fire now he's on the [ __ ]
Broadway doing a play with Denzel I just
bumped into him he got back from New
York he was in the movie and I had never
gone no disrespect
I've seen you on the show with Dennis
Leary what's going on here and he was
from the Bronx and he fueled my anger he
was like I know they don't have no
[ __ ] food I've been in this business
for 20 years nobody's ever sent me out
for lunch and this was like we were out
there like in scary though how many days
he supposed to be honest that's so more
21 in a row all out in Sylmar
I was so more in a [ __ ] stage sound
with one it was it was a it was a true
story it was about a meeting the most
popular one on Radford its Monday night
when Hawk it but that's what if you want
to sell a script you go up there and
make believe you're an alcoholic
because all the big-time directors the
stuff go in there yeah yeah like that's
what seriously the guy who got this
movie made was a guy who played on how
he went to that meeting on Mondays
networking and he would network it was
all heavy-duty people Monday nights up
there is everybody
the guy from office in the gentlemen do
you suck big dude he's up there all the
top
he would have a way to go up there
because it's their own little circle
it's a true story in the 70s there was a
robbery and the two people went into the
meeting and hidden the meeting and I
held everybody capped it for 12 hours
this guy found out about it wrote a
story about it so when they got listen
to the weirdest thing Greg Garcia when I
did the episode with you of let's light
him on fire yeah yeah yeah if you look
at my tooth it's black people think that
the makeup department did there that was
my cocaine habit okay the drip was
already starting to eat this enamel on
the tooth and I caught it
and I gave me one went to a dentist
dentist as Ike it's gonna cost you it
was a day before Christmas 1,500 to do
[Laughter]
that black tooth was starting to rot
yeah and on that movie I did the table
read over here next to a row aroma
mm-hmm yeah there's a little stage in
there I did the table read and there
were some hackers in that movie the
chick that played the the mistress and
Goodfellas was at the table read the guy
from Mission Impossible it died was at
the table read
Jack was at the table read there was
some big name I'm sitting on this I
gotta get this movie's role as me and
they were like we'll call you you know
and when the movie when I signed on it
was thousand dollars a day plus ten for
your agent or something yeah they called
me a year later like what the movies on
but it's 100 a day and we want to take
you out to lunch and they took me to
some shitty Chinese joint in the valley
made me meet him like in Woodland Hills
here and there was three producers and
they sat me down this is the first time
anybody ever had the balls to say this
to me
we're talking and they go you know we
want you for the role but there's only
one problem we've heard about your drug
problem and I just say nothing I go
it doesn't affect who I am or whatever
then I listen was shoot in 21 days in a
row and everybody shoots at every scene
if you're not there we can't shoot
so before you make a decision and tell
us yes we want you to go home and sleep
on yeah because we're gonna need you for
21 days what year is this this is 2007
this is when I quit coke and I went home
and I was furious that my little secret
was out
yeah I was [ __ ] I was ready to [ __ ]
I'm down whoever left my seat without
it's obviously a bail you cut it with
sour cream yeah my favorite joke what
are you cutting this [ __ ] with butter
and it wasn't even my joke what's the
name gave it to me she stole it
who and the guy get went after me I had
to spit in his face at the improv then
he died a cancer but before he died
Jenny know before he died how to do a
movie with him and sit in the room with
him all night we kept looking at him who
who was it one man I'm at the Comedy
Store doing this joke about cocaine
I'm snorting coke every night and one
night I forget what her name was Lou I
love her to death
who's Luca palanquins girlfriend wife
Academy basket tower with Timmy basket
alley Tammy basket al he comes up to me
in a sweet hard way and she goes Joey
you should say you cutting your cut your
coke with butter yeah
so mine out of ten for 20 years Greg I
don't care what the [ __ ] you are you
come up to me with a tagline I'll tell
you yeah yeah yeah but I won't really
use it yeah I'll think about it first
something made me use it yeah it was
funny it's funny something made me use
that's why and it [ __ ] month later
I'm getting threats from this comic this
old-school Jewish comic but I stole his
joke yeah no problem
I wasn't even around when you were doing
that joke if and he kept on on it and
kept on it and every time he come to the
Improv he kept on it I'd see him at
commercial auditions and he would say
[ __ ] to me and at that time my little
addiction god forbid I smack him I go to
jail for 24 hours I'll go crazy I just
want a small coke sticks and stones will
break my bones if I stole you joke I
stole you job with it and I didn't steal
his joke I swear emergency
Joe and one night I went to the improv
had like $18 to short together 20 when I
would smack in the [ __ ] mouth remember
at the improv and the old improv the
checks would be out yeah so you could go
through the checks hxx Drew Carey had 30
bucks I went in there like eighteen
dollars two dollars short over 20 and I
had to go up on stage and I found that
they weren't paying me that night it was
one of those deal when I walked in there
and that guy came up to me and he
squared up on me but you stole my joke
dawg
we're gonna end this tonight before I
just looked at him and spit his [ __ ]
face and it almost knocked him over he
went backwards he couldn't believe
nobody's ever spit in my face ball come
close to me now and I will not stayed he
created a campaign that I stole his
[ __ ] joke but by the way but by the
wall this [ __ ] not by the way it's a
joke so the odds of somebody else well
he was a coke fiend yes and that's at
currently storing those days as I'm sure
somebody else in the eighties wrote it
tended to you know he's we had this war
at the improv they have to hold him back
they gotta hold me back I pushed the
manager the whole [ __ ] deal I get
suspended for 30 days whatever and I got
a call from Nick Swanson he goes do you
want to be in this movie I'm like yeah
be down there Saturday
guess who's in the trailer next to me No
yeah the guy's spit in his face
oh no and when the same scene together
some other guy so in between taste
what's the worst movie that wasn't poor
kid rotten tomatoes almost won under
Grandma's Boy yeah well is the the poor
one one one Nicky walk this way oh yeah
how is it that that got rotten [ __ ]
tomatoes like they they almost gave his
money back he couldn't even the Bank of
America wouldn't cash his check
it was terrible I hate pork but I go in
there on a Saturday morning and my scene
is with this guy are you supposed to
like each other and I went up to Nick's
once I'm like a man and
oh come here for second I told that atom
an atom like he was all that I'm saying
loves all that [ __ ] oh my god wait
what's the scene no do you guys like
each other do you know their promoter is
showing us his movie and we have to
agree to it and so your buddies me you
and partners you me and him a producers
yeah and Lee is showing us point to sell
and the movie ends and I look egan I'm
like I can't even see her [ __ ] like the
agent called me and said I can't even
read the lines Tianna so bad so we had a
I had a walk-in with Don Johnson and
sitting next to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the whole time he was talking [ __ ]
like once they broke his for lunch he
kept telling Nick Swanson the guy who
stole my joke and at one point out of
town at that point he had a guy like
working with because he was he telling
people you spend his face oh yeah he's
got no class he spent my face and I'll
spit in your [ __ ] face again keep it
up [ __ ] I was crazy yeah like
throat cancer and died good lord yes ah
how good Dwight what happened to the
woman that told you to say that I went
she got in the middle and she stuck up
for me and you know what everything but
the guy didn't believe her the guy just
had it out the guy just wanted to pick a
fight yeah so that's it he I had a
cancer so wait were you wishing cancer
are like no I didn't wish nothing [ __ ]
all I wanted was for him to leave me the
[ __ ] alone okay
you know he won't remember he went on
last comic towards the end he didn't
okay he was an old guy uh he went out of
that comic away and he came in 16th so
now that game was some plug so I walked
into the in problem he wants to [ __ ]
pick a fight with me and I'm like dog I
just want to go home and pick up my 20
and go home it's not with the cats you
know I went in the comedy store I went
to the you know the bathrooms in the
manor yeah I haven't been in those
bathrooms apparently since when we used
to that we used to the main room used to
be empty the woman is
yeah the woman's breath that main room
use no no no the men's room when you've
worked going that through the little
hallway and you take a left right away
and that's way the original yeah yeah
but that room used to be the main room
used to be empty most nights but and but
that was the bathroom that everybody
went to do coke and I hadn't been in
that bathroom since because I don't use
the main room bathroom because it was
its mm-hmm it used to be basically set
up for us to do coke those bathrooms old
yeah it because nobody was using that
bathroom except though it me and you and
probably Schubert and the back piano in
the main room that was for cocaine yeah
but I would go back there by myself and
I will hear [ __ ] spirits so I would
not snort coke like but the basement to
do then no but I never what the basement
to snort coke there's no reason it
always have the help to the basement
yeah and the woman's bathroom is the
best at the Comedy Store in the mainland
because they have a little couch you can
sit her down you could sit it down and
rub her back and let her tell you about
her problems but there's some cocaine
and then sue Cal I mean you don't say
next thing you know you're making in
there the [ __ ] it's a really cool
they're like a little cat yeah yeah yeah
the bathroom that brings me I've been
going to County store for 21 years and
nothing brings me a better memory then
the belly room bathroom Josh at the time
had a child and he was involved with
this woman that was how we didn't make a
show for her at the time
a reality show and was the real deal and
everybody by the balls and she was a
gorgeous woman she was 40 pounds
overweight and she was still I remember
her coming in a month after she had
Jacob into the union and every man in
the room looked at her she was my mum
she was she had a face so her and Josh
had going through some stuff and one
night Josh you know Josh this has at
that time Josh had a weird sense of
humor he had a different type of sensor
here it was a little darker yeah so I
guess he was a little darker yeah she
gets home one night at 6:00 in the
morning Joshy house ever
has a heart attack and it takes [ __ ]
twenties annexes and she falls over and
Josh is like you're gonna die cuz I
can't pick you up and you know like Josh
he's just saying nasty things to her
then the ambulance came and they tried
to pull her out
josh is like I'm telling you and I gotta
get her out that door cuz she was a
voluptuous woman like just tremendous
knockers she was big big face and she
didn't give a [ __ ] no she did she would
wear a miniskirt she didn't care he
didn't care now like you have to give
her like if if I have to put a list of
most memorable people in my life she's
in the top 20 at that point whatever
happened between them was whatever but
for that time she really would make you
laugh in time the time not from sometime
she was funny she was fun to play
I remember she used to take $20 out of
his ATM machine every day listen if you
want to piss Josh I have always said
that they should do another fear factor
and taking you and hold them back like
hold and like put a gun for their father
says that father said but then take the
ATM machine and take the thing and take
their money out and cut the 20s and a
half and then watch it you just go crazy
like ah she would take a 20 she she
talked Josh into taking it into her
giving him a credit card with her name
on it like so they could split the
household unities but she was taking on
a 20 for lunch every day she did
clerical work I could spit in his face
and he wouldn't get his mad at that 20
he had so mad at that 20 you remember
you have s bits of his life was about
that 20 he said you know what that's
like
that's 140 a week that's 280 a month
that's fine 60 that's you know money
money we don't want turkey burgers I can
eat ya like a bit about I would say the
hat in hand then I would ask him for 20
just the [ __ ] destroy it yeah like
because that's the lie he would go on
the run in those days you didn't go on
the computer because you think and find
that you were broke when you didn't even
know you were broke he got what you but
you're missing the bit that I was making
$1000 a month so $20 a day was you was a
lot of [ __ ] money
I mean turkey burgers and [ __ ] beans
and she's not shape clerical job she
would bring stuff home and that's what
she was eating you know everybody was
talking him the brother the brother
couldn't pay rent but he told every
night from what's that place sanku
chicken saying coach Icahn the [ __ ]
mix Bowl it's not like 10 Hindus in the
apartment that's when I would leave I
don't give a [ __ ] I gotta go and then
one night he was getting tortured from
all over I'm living with a mooching off
him the chick is taking twenty a day and
then there's one business calls to
Compton and the only person those black
people walk into an argument in the
house would night yeah and he's like I
didn't call Crenshaw it was a house
Crenshaw and that day selling you to see
like ten cents just add it up and we had
a black girlfriend in Crenshaw and I'll
never forget Josh both going like wait a
second wait a second Jonathan you're
trying to sit there I'm walking into
this like excited I had a $20 bag of
coke I'm taking Josh with me Malia's
gonna babysit you know we're out and
josh is like so you're trying to tell me
you you got a black girlfriend but
you're not calling Crenshaw and he would
sit there and go you know just cuz I
have a black girlfriend doesn't know I
know any other boy and it was just
[ __ ] establish the other part I go I
go you teach at Crenshaw High yeah it
was this thing it's not not you you're
not making that colleagues I still know
me and I'm like okay well that's a
pretty strong denial like me say yeah
but I was the crazy sorry he would deny
it to dis that he would deny it to which
I respect yeah but like yeah once you
once you once he's in he's in but you
know what here's the thing is that like
when there's a lot okay
a friend of mine just came to my show in
Boston and when we were like 14 years
old there was one of these big town
tennis tournaments and we were in it and
we ended up playing each other and you
got a referee your own match he's been
cheating the whole time
so match point I serve he swings any
misses and he goes do-over and I'm like
what do you mean I think he was two over
I go why what do you need to do over for
he goes you didn't see that butterfly I
go what and he was that butterfly go I
didn't want to hit it with my racket we
got to do a duo and ice his name's Anton
I go Anton there's only two of us here
one of us is lying like that we were
both looking at where the ball was how
can you look at my face and tell me
there was a butterfly and he just you
know he just he goes do over butterfly
and I was like because I'm lucky with it
he's never gonna I know guys like that
are just never gonna break they're never
gonna say there was no butterfly yeah
and there was only two was there
whatever how'd you do on the do-over I'd
be defined raisi argument him and then
we leave so this one night Malia's been
going on I'm not coming home till 6:00
and Josh is on his last straw enjoy
shells are the one night she eats a
bunch of xanax and she's she doesn't she
can't even write the note and she passes
out and Josh has to call my mom while I
go over that Josh calls me and says did
you see your I going to I tried so I get
to you always fell Maliha yeah but I
didn't see her at six I had no money in
those days to be splitting cook till six
and if I had I'll be by myself say goes
last night she had a bunch of pills I
don't know why she did that hospital
they pumped his stomach
a cheeseburger came out spare ribs
you know she ate at some [ __ ] good so
it's like it's Thursday morning with
it's Tuesday morning when this happens
so when you try to commit suicide they
hold you for 48 hours like there's a
lien yeah hold on mmm-hmm well Wednesday
night I'm outside standing in the hall
at the Comedy Store outside when my name
is and all I see walking into the
Congress but Malia and she walks right
up to me like nothing happened like I
didn't hear about what happened yet me a
hug and says where's the dude with the
coke can I go you just like I tried to
explain to her
no no I got money so she goes she knew
the guy she gets the packages she goes
away can we do a bump I go and they
gotta go upstairs believe it and the
whole walk on the way up I'm trying to
get out like what happened but I don't
have the balls to ask her yeah so we
finally get to the bathroom she empties
the whole five packages out like it's
just the [ __ ] little mound and she's
chopping it up with an ATM card did I
finally whose name was on that 18 gram
it was like Chewie would give you six
20s for a hundred those days so it was
like a grand it was a good grand point -
that's a lot of coke and she cut it into
two lines I looked like a movie him
before you do that can I ask you a
question
weren't you just Devin say in the song
she goes yeah
can I go what are you out she goes I
talked them out of it [ __ ] and she said
something to me she goes I talked them
out of it I'm not crazy and with that
she just did the whole line of coke yeah
and that is every time I go to the belly
room to do a show that memory comes back
to me of her going looking at me and
going I'm not crazy
yeah you just need a [ __ ] half a gram
and one line and you're sitting there
telling me am I crazy about this yeah
that's my material banality right Nik
every time I go to the ballet room I sit
in that booth and I still remember that
lady's bathroom that's when there was no
shows in the belly yeah there was
nothing during the week it was just the
original so you could snort coke in the
main room or the belly room told your
heart was and which is upstairs belly
room she yeah man she uh you didn't take
the card away here's the crazy thing she
was the one making money we had decided
because she I was like I'm gonna go out
at night and perform so I can't work
during the day and go out at night I'll
take care of the kids you get a job and
then
night which she preferred anyways yeah
so that was easy it just you know she
was doing coke at work though dude yeah
that would that dude what you doing did
she have a boss that's right oh yeah and
one of the air kind of girl never had a
boss
yeah ass that wasn't the coke and then
she the boss is buying coke that's how
she was getting some her coke yeah I
think so and what did they do
she working an insured or something like
that yeah something like that she worked
maybe an insurance office but it was it
wasn't my healthiest relationship I hope
not no watch the company a
peanut-butter-and-jelly corporation yeah
I've heard about yeah I still owe with
$250 yeah it was outstanding tab does he
get you lose yeah you ain't the [ __ ]
outta you come back at all this reuse
this oh I can't you know and using use
like a mother surprise it's only three
to be honest no he was real day you just
had a cooler and you moved around town
writer with a page man yeah then we
would make the same which is in the
apartment and we got shut down by the
Health Board really yeah because can
make sandwiches at your house not on the
ground
my kids were putting I'm surprising I
found out we were doing like we were
doing alright you're doing well yeah not
well but an enough like when you're
making $1,000 a month if you add an
extra $400 that's a lot yeah you know so
and I was trying to get air conditioning
for my Saturn you remember that [ __ ]
car it had no air conditioning and the
st. Bernard used to ride in it so you
could either ride with the windows down
but the air there was like a tornado of
hair yeah and so we you would get out
and look like a wookie
you know I mean or you could roll up the
windows but if you rolled up the windows
it's hot as oh yeah
insuring there with the st. Bernard and
the kids sometimes I think he's
something from good so hot they just
passed out like sometimes I'd be
sweating in the car and I'd look in the
back and they reduce all asleep I'm like
man I hope I'm not doing bad [ __ ] to
their brains right now
we took all the cabbages and there was
home dad couldn't be covered in hair
yeah yeah there's only a TV shows yeah
we took that card to Lake Havasu no air
conditioner it's 114 our last hour got
the sunroof open and the windows open
just livin I'm warm man and all the
[ __ ] flies and mosquitoes yeah
there's a little Visine bottle then we
get they were stoned to the gills and
[ __ ] coke he decides to put the Visine
there's eyeballs it was a hundred and
eight the handicap room you remember and
I didn't have a shower with a head I had
to sit down in the shower and it shot
water at my chest and there was a snake
in my [ __ ] room it was and that gig
wasn't Brian Dunkleman with us that we
had wasn't Brian with us first of all
you ready least cuz Lee's getting him to
calm me I just want to drop by he was
150 for the night yeah and you had to
drive down there and you got 150 so you
already lost eighty in gas yeah yeah
like it's Forks oh it was five down and
five back you had to go over the London
Bridge
yeah it was much it the one yeah 150 150
that last weekend we went we got him for
250 because it was dirty white people
weekend at it was the weekend when
everybody goes down and they jump from
boat to boat you can see the chlamydia
flow he may have that's disgusting we
have to judge something we had a judge
and do him we like bat beats out of it
the funny thing was that what did you
judge like a bikini contest something
stupid but that was an ugly weekend
because his cousin Scott had a party on
that Street Scott was living with your
other brother and they were living in
Hollywood towards Mimi's Cafe up the
corner tight by that neighborhood by the
Jewish neighborhood to Bono's Gary Gary
and Gary Aryan Danny and Danny no it was
Scott oh I think and then they were
living there cuz we went over there one
night and we listened to Santana and we
went there one day and the cops came at
2:00 in the morning we've all jacked out
it's got went to the door it was like
thirty of us and Scott went to the door
into the top
was on party of five he's signing
autographs and the cops went away we had
to be in Havasu at 12 so it was 2:00 in
the morning we got [ __ ] six grams of
blow or like what we gonna do you want
it's not those six let's just drive all
right and we left we stopped somewhere
we got a bunch of beers Carol the
stripper dumped them it had to be like
eight of us and three of us were
performing yeah we were getting for
hotel rooms of three hotel rooms so
somebody has a share yeah with $150
hundred fifty I think they pay they only
paid for one meal right when you were
performing in the bar yeah and so you
got it and if you drank you blew your
money is it give you phone to break even
what do you mean if you drank there's no
way you're going to one of those gay and
it was one of those gigs there was a lot
of those gigs in fact I just watched
that movie where you go into gang and
the waitress would ask you what you
wanted
you're like I'll take a beer and bring
Leah beer and all of a sudden you know
tonight you get paid they give you a tab
and you're like what's this for oh you
drinking you're like the waitress asked
me if I wanted something yeah I'm saying
like what you were the guest I took you
with a guest knowing knives it was like
the Blues Brothers now we got to pay for
our beer right here yeah you know you
gotta pay you pay with 250 but the
band's rank to 80 so I'd appreciate like
that used to have like I did this rule
one time in st. Louis with Jody verdict
uh holy [ __ ] she was the feature act
boozing I kept telling her buy a bottle
at the bar and drinking in your room
that huh she would be at the bar and I
remember Sunday night she was crying I
know what are you crying about and she
goes I held them 72 dollars to go we
think those [ __ ] beers before free
yeah you know a bar will give you two
beers
usually tell you don't abuse them
they'll give you to the etiquettes once
they see you're an alkie they're like
turn on the light brown yeah seven
dollars of cocktail we don't give a [ __ ]
there's no judge no comic discount the
last club I went to
forget where was where they said so you
get soft drinks for free and everything
on the menu half off and I was like what
about bottled water they said no that
you gotta pay for water she has soft
drinks and where was that but I said to
the guy right when he said it to me I
said this will be the last time I
perform here it was the first and last
when he was like why do you say that I
was like that's not man that's not like
I have to pay for water and he goes well
I have to pay for it I said yeah but do
you know you're the only club in the
country that makes people pay for water
and he was like that can't be true I'm
like that is so [ __ ] true there's a
there's a refrigerator filled with water
when you walk into a room but dude was
stood fast to it soft drinks half of the
menu was crazy
he wouldn't even like not even a drink
if it was if I was like can I get a shot
Saturday night late and we can do a shot
with the crowd charged me for I was
[ __ ] crazy but I never I can't like
you here's the thing when I go to on a
gig the hotel you put me up in tells me
a lot about how you want our
relationship to be you know I mean this
is that very first time you go if they
didn't spend the 20 extra dollars that I
know it would cost to put me in just a
one step up so that's an extra $60 three
nights if they don't want to spend that
then that tells me something about okay
yeah there's no how you're perceived
this buyout you're being treat and this
is how we're starting the relationship
you know what I mean yeah and so a lot
of times I'm like okay and that also
judges that tells me down the road like
you sometimes you have club owners
sometimes you have club owners ask you
for favors and there's some guys I'll do
anything for and there's some guys that
know yeah because right off the bat they
told you what they think of you you know
what I mean yeah you sure that happens
in your when you first got yes dude yeah
people treat you a lot different than
what they treat you now yeah oh yeah
sure gnarly looking
yeah I've been nice to him he was only
yesterday yeah yeah but I also came up
like I started as you know the lowest
getting scripts and lunches and all that
stuff so for the most part people were
nice to me so as soon as I you know when
I got the opportunity nice you got you
got to was there ever set you were on
when you were at that spot were you will
that that said that person ran a set
where you were like that's how I'm gonna
run a set I mean I think it took I tried
to take the best things from different
people cuz you see things cuz nobody's
perfect at it and somebody come work for
me and go okay well I'm gonna do that
but I'm not gonna do that you know that
as you work for people running shows
that's how you kind of do it you could
it's not like just good and bad you just
collect you see what's working and
what's not working and then you kind of
adapt all that I think why do you think
then some people make their sets so
tense I don't know it's so crazy to me
because you can walk onto a set and then
people are just they're not happy to be
there I guess if they're you know a lot
of times people get behind on these sets
you know they get they get behind and
now it's super stressful and you don't
know if you're gonna have something next
week and Bubba and I can't I cannot ever
let myself get anywhere near being
behind or I'll feel that anxiety then so
I'm like no I got it I got to stay ahead
of this and then I think it's it from
there you can be more relaxed I think a
lot of it sometimes is that well you
dude you're up you know you're up at
like 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning
sometimes writing yeah sometimes I like
to get early start yeah yeah like you
you you I remember I asked you because
you don't live necessarily close to your
office and I was like how's traffic and
you're like I don't know I'm in my car
for I am yeah what'd you get that pretty
quick in there for it so just to write
it but you're there six hours before
anybody else yeah those on the only
single camera shows I did that because
because then I could look at what they
did the day earlier in the writers room
and I can read through it and put notes
and whatever else and then give it back
to them when they come in and then I can
go to set because you can't be in two
places at one time
and a lot of times somebody's running a
show they want to be in the room and
they want to be on the floor watching
you know the acting and everything
making sure that's getting getting done
the way they want it to and then people
in the room are just waiting and so then
and that's when you get these terrible
hours so I would just get up early and
go back and forth that is it
so because in writers room sometimes
you're waiting for the you you know
whoever you are
yeah unless you have instructions yeah
you know yeah going on then you but if
you're waiting for notes sometimes it's
like you can just be sitting in front of
your at your desk just waiting for our
yeah yeah so you get up early do the
work and so every because you want again
everybody again though dude
not keeping people there for 16 hours if
you don't have to makes people happier
to show up to [ __ ] set you know what
I mean yeah and also like I noticed like
some writing writing rooms you go in
there and you don't know what you're
doing all day long so you just [ __ ]
around because you don't know you're
gonna be here till 2:00 in the morning
anyway
you know it and whereas otherwise if you
just give them instructions at beginning
the day they're like alright as soon as
we get this done we're home so then they
see an NSA no and they have better hours
cuz they get out of there they don't
stand around while people tell stories
for like you know for hours or anything
then let's get going
let's get going there's not as much
gambling with dice in the corner what do
you do now now so now you sit you wait
to see if you get picked up do you do
any writing at all what do you have I'll
probably proactively be starting to
think about season three the guest book
just hoping that you know something
comes of it and the good thing about
that show is every episode is different
so even if I come up with like three or
four stories for season three and they
don't do it I could use those stories
someplace else because they're just you
know they're just random standalone
stories how many stories did you write
for this season ten did 10 scripts LA I
got like how about how many did you have
oh oh how many did well how big is your
catalog Oh from from the stories that I
left in guest books only three of them
this season are in season two and then
the rest I might just sit down and come
up with do you like it more writing
these that are standalone episodes but
they also have three lines they do a
little bit they have through the whole
thing guys so do you prefer that or do
you like writing the show like Earl they
kind of had definitely out of through
them I like right now I like this one I
like this one because it just the fact
that you can do absolutely anything from
one episode to the next episode yeah you
know and then you know then they're all
written too and you can be shooting them
and you're thinking like okay like we
got to this one episode Joey Joey was in
Joey's in two episodes and the first one
he was in
didn't know he was gonna be in the one
later and then I was writing that part
and then I forgave him a little
backstory so it would make sense let me
know this what are we gonna do this I'll
put up five hundred yeah but we gotta
figure out a way to let people guess
what I did
here's gonna be a proper so here's gonna
be the problem with this they aired it
as a sneak peek last night
they showed me yeah doing it yeah so so
they showed it the real premiere is next
Tuesday on the 23rd but they did show
something after baseball like way after
baseball after the post game they put
her nobody said nothing I saw like one
thing on Twitter they somebody had a
frozen screen of yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't even think it's like a
really a spoiler to say what you're
doing no no nobody all right I won't say
all right okay all right proud of my
work yeah you should be proud of your
work how many how many Taylor I don't
know we just laughed three more than I
wanted
oh my god we had a blast I just laughs I
love you know I did a movie with I did
an all-star movie about that Howard
Hughes guy flies what I'm yeah and it
had like Alec Baldwin everyone else did
it and I got to tell you something that
was the most uncomfortable set really
just tense it was just too much too much
I thought once you have too many stars
in the movie see Matt the name of the
movie is what do you see there's a lot
about what was your first one bass
ketball
yeah I remember when you booked that and
I had no idea what I was doing yeah I
remember when you booked that but they
were so big at the time they would just
blow it off when you also in the out
Baldwin yeah Walt was just looking to
IMDB Jodie as when you booked that first
movie well you um did you have time to
enjoy it and be excited about it or did
you get nervous right away Garcia I
didn't know what I was doing
yeah you have no idea
not to know what you're doing yeah so
was it instant anxiety the first thing I
booked was an industrial I booked a
movie in Colorado that's still floating
around that one win award I hit her
I thought during the trunk of a car I
was based off me the girl knew me a
father knew me that's funny so she wrote
smiles thanks you did you get a copy of
it no we're 1015 up 2016 fly away
something and I went to I told these
guys that I came here to shoot a CBS
pilot that started with six pages of
dialogue yeah and every time I would go
to rehearse I would lose another page
until I shot the pilot when I was
basically a deaf-mute because I had no
idea what I was doing yeah there was no
formal acting there was no just thrown
right into the fire right I took
whatever in high school
improv my freshman year that's it I
didn't know nothing and then I didn't
know about acting classes 200 a months
I'm smoking coke I got no time for that
200 a month and then that booked
basketball I remember I went to NYPD
Blue for a guest star audition there's a
coke dealer nine pages and I remember
they stopped me after three and they
were like that's great thank you for
coming in yeah but it was a bosco
building so it was all it's a mile walk
in those days in those days have you
read for my people you got to read the
bicycle building all the way they must
hate it Steven Bochco
look up Alec Baldwin I guess it's on
your thing
I look up Alec Baldwin okay and look up
what movies he did in 2016
whatever you had the excited about that
movies oh we were all really excited
when again there was 5500 a week yeah in
but they were because they were that was
right around also right after that
[ __ ] VHS with Santa fighting Jesus
you remember
yeah yeah is there VHS and then South
Park was like crushing it and they came
in with a movie and we were all like oh
you dumb be a star
yeah what if NYPD blue and as I was
walking down the hallway
as soon as I hit the end Libby Goldstein
opened the door and it was such a
coincidence that I had a shirt Paris can
wait which string know which strings on
it and she goes are you here for the
audition yeah that she gave me sometimes
I never uh she was got two minutes and I
read it and I went back and read it and
I didn't think of that and I was living
in what's now uh when people come from
other countries a hostel the hostel used
to be a six dollar hotel on Schrader
yeah in the middle I was staying there
okay phone call from Rocky like there's
no anybody in the building named Diaz
Joe Diaz I'm gonna had to run down for
the pay phone and it was my manager and
he's like hey man you booked the bass
ketball it's three weeks 5,500 a week
but you got a joint sag up to 50 yeah
who's got 1250 and I called Danny
Robinson like 11 he wasn't even my agent
still doing it by the way he called yeah
he's got the hottest act in Hollywood
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah is he is that
good for him he had he called the
production company and made him pay for
this addict and I went on there I've
told this story a thousand times I was
pure [ __ ] joke yeah so they had roller
skates on the set and they had a truck
full of Roma skates so I went to the
truck one day and I saw a size 14 and I
just took it and walked out like nothing
put it in my car
and I stopped at Swiss Chalet when it
was hard one of those and I walked in
like I got these here for Christmas
[Applause]
there was no computers then there was no
beep yeah yeah yeah I don't think we had
me kill a balloonist or let me look it
up and the guy comes back and he goes I
think they're like 289 would you take
cash yeah yeah so pretty soon I was
going on this celery day and just
stealing a pair of roller skates every
day the ones that they would give me to
go I would go get and go back to the
same place it's a different there was so
different ski shop every I remember the
day you told me the story about getting
Christmas presents at Target
because before computers he would pick
up like a big blanket and you know
something else and then he would walk
him up and bring it right to the pattern
counter and be like I got those as a
gift there you go and then that's how he
buy a Christmas presents way before this
system came from one yeah the one year I
was broke I know if I get going into
Toys R Us with no that's what I saw with
my daughter and I would just take like a
$300 stencil yeah and go up to the front
and go I got this for Christmas they
would go yeah but a receipt no because
from December 15th to Fallon tines day
though khana everything yeah receipt
yeah it's Gibbs yeah that guess we
definitely bought it here you know but I
would do I would get that Jeffery money
[Laughter]
they would a bite yeah boy just
returning things that never left the
store well it didn't affect him I mean
they're doing great I was doing it to so
many people in 94 5 like I used to hang
out in front of a Kmart and wait for
people to walk out for receipts them
well oh that's right doesn't forget one
time I found the receipt for $1 loan
more yeah so I couldn't go back and then
get it so I drove to Longmont Colorado
to the Kmart there went right up with
the it went to an assistant in the long
department go hey where's this lawnmower
because it's right there and I went
right over they called it and the thing
they go
my wife just got me is I got one here's
the receipt I got one and he gave me
four hundred plus tax and I walked out
of there I was doing that everywhere
yeah there was like a little in it the
first people who suspect knew I was
doing it on the road yeah I was doing it
on triple roids
I will go to Trimble runs and steal a
tenth and then put it back and give me
179 for the [ __ ] ten yeah I will
bring him back take it and I got along
my mind finally tied us yeah move up me
and Idaho Falls and and they catch you
they caught me because they caught me on
the computer okay they caught me after
the game of the cache they arrested me
they gave me a ticket and then they let
me loose I never went back there's a
warrant and Idaho Falls all right
and I got a call this week to go to
Blackfoot know I'd hide the whole yeah
to do a movie guy goes you gonna have to
fly into Salt Lake then to hide the
whole Falls and right there the
conversation that your know how crazy
and it's funny that I was just a serial
shoplifter that wouldn't even walk out
of the store yeah and you were a
magician at a seven left I would come to
Josh's obstacle what are you doing till
he's like I'm going on with some chicks
we're gonna get an Eightball what do I
need a hundred could be back in an hour
and I would shoot to the mall in Boulder
and there was all there was a maid DNF
but made the mmm can't we have another
blankets and then something happened
that really [ __ ] I started making big
money
expresso machines once the expresso
machine came out with the combination
cappuccino yeah they were four hundred I
was doing two three a day and you know
you just walk right in grabbing right
right into the right way to the register
so today I would go to Century City
Wednesday I will go to Woodland Hills
Thursday on what he was like I wouldn't
even get [ __ ] crazy let's go to San
Diego eat his steak on the way back and
get a hotel room like I would just go to
anywhere they had now you need to roll
of those stickers yeah hit you with when
you can be walking around oh good I
never forget one damn eight seventeen
hundred bucks and I got so high on weed
and I walked into economy works this is
why I was a comic in the beginning but
not getting spots I paid to see somebody
and I'll never forget I was so high that
I took the money out and put it on the
counter and paid the guy and I sat down
I left 17 allow is on the counter and I
came back and I left my money like no
you did and I'm like you [ __ ]
robbed me but it was like nothing I'll
go get another 79 the next day and stole
four coffee machines he was crazy
he got to the point where I would get
coked up at night and I was making notes
I was going to contact all these
companies and explain to them I could do
security for them like on six like I
wanted to be on 60 minutes they would
have put you to jail
but that's the thing I would have broken
their system everybody wants to know how
you break this system if I come to you
and say Joshua if I come in peace yeah I
robbed 11 million dollars from you last
year you like well you didn't let me
give you the proof yeah and I say to you
this is how I robbed it and this is how
other people are robbing you you're
gonna be interested in what I gotta say
to you don't you think they call it hard
no no no no if you're gonna stop again
what a great dose and I'm good one thing
is it every one of the companies you
stole from now bankruptcy is the only
one I know when I was on bail for
kidnapping Sears would put their CDs
right by the door
yeah when I was a kid there was a series
of North Bergen but it was also a Sears
in Richmond Park and they had car
stereos that they were put by the door
if there was a hundred car stereos I
swear on my mother's grave I stole 98 so
I'm out on bail for kidnapping and the
high this album is that Bruce
Springsteen for CD kid with him to pick
at all huh yeah 87 maybe 80 I don't know
what you kind of even know dawg I was
stealing those every day for nine ninety
five but the CD store in town will give
me 25 hours I was going in I'm out on
kidnapping
bail for kidnapping and I'm going in
there every day putting stocking all
this to see these together and at one
point I would just pick up a stack of
CDs and walk out
came us Sears and go to my car go up on
the hill we sell the [ __ ] CDs and I
get 150 for the day that's enough for me
in those days I'm one day [ __ ] I set
it up and I'm walking out of there and I
hear hey you stop and this is skinny
black security guard they got a cart and
I start running and I'm seized at the
guy he's dumb got a cart and in those
days I could run I was still not heavy
I had to be 27 28 I'm on bail and I'm
dodging the dog I'm dodging him I'm
[ __ ] jumping over trees on my coach
every two minutes I throw another CD out
of his ship by I must decide I must had
20 CDs yeah so they got me for finally a
cop car pulled over and I'm like I'm
[ __ ] and they asked me what my name
was they're like completely like I would
get out of the Congo robbed but I
believe my license and everything in the
car I would never go in there what ID so
I could be whoever all right
so by the way good note that's a long
time by the way I knew you were couple
of years yeah I'm a business what my
name is don't worry about so they took
me to jail when I went under the
impression I came I told my was somebody
else this is the funniest guest book
ever I walk into the jail
I just been in there for a month and a
half you know how is yeah I had the
place I was running the kool-aid scam so
I walk into the county jail here but st.
Joe way oh [ __ ] it's party time now the
card had I can't tell you the alias I
used what's it say I used the alias Josh
wolf the printer print card had Josh
both know it had Josh wolf on it and the
cop was still calling me Joey so joy
like what is this cop than I look up
they [ __ ] fingerprinted me which is
no good because NCIC will give him the
report in a few days but it wasn't now
like now I fingerprint two seconds well
they know a lot yeah and those days had
to send that off and depending on what
crime you did it could take 30 days yeah
so another forget I gave him a
fingerprints they put me in the cell now
I had to get out
you got to produce an ID I go I lost my
beat my big eyes well somebody has to
come in here and say who you are so I
called my girlfriend at the time and I'm
like hey it's Josh wolf and she said
what are you talking about it's Josh
wolf I'm bulma County Jail but I
wouldn't even let us say Joey what are
you talk
I took down a date a couple nights ago
you're in Boulder County Jail come down
here and identify me I get out and she
came down and they bought the whole
story and they let me out his Josh wolf
and me being the loyal guy that I am I
went to court because Joshua he was a
dear friend of money day my game he's a
deer I grew up with him and so I went to
court did the volunteer work paid the
fine as somebody and I went on probation
for six months and somebody else I'd go
back home but I bump into him and we're
talking that didn't want any girls that
I have to tell you somebody who's my man
that is a volunteer service the
volunteer I did was working at the aids
unit for some reason I go I want to do
at the age unit and they made me go to
the age unit in time downtown and paint
it but because at that time
gay guys were getting with AIDS were so
getting ridiculed it was 97 yeah people
still throwing bottles out of his [ __ ]
there was a guard cop down this is a
funny this is how life works we were
having a conversation last night about
God two nights ago or something and I
said that I don't believe there is a God
but there's situations that lead you to
the places where you got to think back
and go there might not be a god but
there's something mm-hmm so every dad
would go to paint the wall there was a
cop there with a holster first couple
days he treated me like a criminal
I was but after that he started talking
to me and he noticed I had a heart and
he had a heart and when I finished
painting after the 60 hours of community
service they turned to me when then he
was you ever have a problem in this town
you call me he goes I know you made a
mistake and he gave me his card and I
kept in touch with him you don't read
those mm-hmm
relentless I would call him once a week
and say what's up everything's good
so when I went through my divorce I
started calling him and I'm like she's
not giving me the kid and he would calm
me down and bla ba ba ba ba Bob and one
day I had two felonies and my ex-wife's
boyfriend called me aspect and I go I
can either go to jail or let this guy
keep calm you know what I'm gonna go to
jail have my friend to send me a fax
machine and I'll write jokes for Jay
Leno this is where my head was 1995
so I [ __ ] smack the guy at a Safeway
and the cops came who was the cop that
came the guy and he came right to me and
took my story first and now the cop was
like we got to put him away and the guys
like he ain't going nowhere he called
him respect we're in the city limits of
Boulder you can't use a racial slur in
the city limits a bulb it's a free smack
to the mouth very smack to the mouth
because of 1988 of the chick called JJ
Flanagan the n-word and he smacked her
and they got away with it because it's
it's it was instinct yeah so they didn't
charge me but that cop that's how that's
why I say there's got to be something
out there because that cop the other
guys holding his face with an ice pack
usually a cop those to him yeah he came
right to me and I thought well there's
the [ __ ] that's been [ __ ] with
me for the last two years and I couldn't
take it no more he got what he got maybe
we put my hands on Ethan relax you don't
know what and the other guy was like a
white top and he listened to the story
oh he struck him he was like my boy is
not going nowhere and then when they
sent people to break my ribs that time
and they came oh yeah they hit my dog
with the two-by-four
I got the wrong guy and I hit him
that's the cop I called I got a guy here
with a broken rib cage and [ __ ] ice
just took my foot in his mouth what do
you want me to do it'll because I'll be
there in ten minutes
yeah and he came over and we took
wrapper like a paint wrapper for floor
we put him in the trunk of a police car
and there was no cameras in those days
we proved up by the ambulance in Boulder
that cop was solid he was sound good
friends yeah solid yeah didn't ask no
questions at home the truth ago I was
watching the ESPN a football game and I
let my dog out cuz in those days had a
remote control just open the garage with
dog a broadside and I heard them hit the
dog I came down the two guys jumped me
and I grabbed one of them and kicked
them and hit him with the two-by-four
and I kicked him in the mouth and I
could hear his teeth crack and it was
tremendous so I couldn't down my won-won
I just been on probation yeah so I
called him like a man Hill derf these
guys jumped me handle it because I'll be
right over there he came over he kicked
the guy in the stomach we put them up we
put him in the trunk we left it open and
we just drove me tell you ambulance and
dropped him off through the back of
mergency so it wouldn't even see him he
knows don't ever say anything fanny
Bonnie that was it
he's probably dead name is an old man
but my secret died with him all those
people dead Greg Garcia you did it again
another masterful [ __ ] TV show
premieres next Tuesday next Tuesday we
got you in the first man the first one
on the 23rd yeah and then a week later
on the thirty two weeks later today
you'll be in the fourth one yet Jesus
Christ yeah yeah so on the dirty if my
Netflix special comes out okay
so then we got [ __ ] going on for a few
weeks and you just got a specially
released special it's on my website
comedian Josh wolf calm it's called
father of the year it's $5 five hours
comedian was on a [ __ ] subway now get
the same $15 from your husband for lunch
exactly I like breaking it up I see how
how a mad he gets he would talk about it
constantly and like I would ask him for
20 bucks like I would say thing women
coming out of 20 and he was like look at
me like really like really 20 was he you
could even say the number 20 run yes a
1948 you know last night 64 she because
33 20 20 let me tell you about [ __ ]
20 it was because I I remember just
remembered the joke you know what the
joke was mmm was it the one where cuz
she called me a Jew remember she was
like it's 20 dollars a day you Jew she
call me a Jew because I was saying 20
dollars a day is not a big deal but at
the end of that's 30 days in a month
that's $600 $600 is a big deal $20 not a
big deal and she was like you just count
that much cuz you're a Jew and I was
like you think I count because I'm a Jew
and she goes yeah I go why you're Asian
you want me to say it so you'll
understand she said yeah I said oh you
uh spend it too much a money you know
spending no more I don't know how this
relationship didn't work yeah she hated
that joke you are spending too much
money and no spending no more she 5 I
tell you some she's not only Thai food
yeah because she would never wash the
dishes and there was always flies she
was done yeah if that [ __ ] had to wash
the dish it would kill her they would
kill Josh bull
every time you saw Josh she was washing
dishes yeah cuz Josh wouldn't take it no
more they would be how long did this
last yeah man well 20 [ __ ] years yeah
that's not one of years of abuse no it
was 20 hours jakey
yeah but all this jakey 21 so it's nine
18 years ago you got when you got your
first deal she's saying you're a note
that she wanted to escalate
yeah she wanted sound like she
like a $30,000 car just like I got a
Taser a hospital II don't he was the
only invention that man she called me
she said she'll leave me alone
but she's gonna come yes she wanted like
a [ __ ] thirty thousand bow she was a
good never stop but you know what I mean
you had to laugh you gotta laugh ya had
to laugh you had to laugh she was funny
God she was funny but like also a little
bananas you know it [ __ ] could sing
like Brian yeah yeah yeah she could
definitely say hmm she could say if she
was she had funny she said funny [ __ ]
and when she got drunk she didn't look
Asian just her eyes looked Lloyd mm-hmm
that's it but everything else was an
Asian about it yeah but there was
something about that just made you
[ __ ] do it she didn't give a [ __ ] did
not give a [ __ ] yeah you were the TV
[Laughter]
second you have no situational awareness
man he's only six inches away from you
hot dog professional as vice versa I got
told you I got on a plane and look
around I see everybody with your phones
it's every man South I'm on a plane
tonight this time what this times out
[ __ ] and I can hear it with the
explosion on the Jag and I know the guy
next to me has to like get the vibration
next to you next time I'm gonna fart
you have you never sitting next to me I
don't want you next time you're at the
back of dungeon
I love getting upgraded the first class
and I just sit there one day and as
people will buy a looking for my go get
to the dungeon I feel these la people
with like they always have extra quite
to make themselves be special yeah
and I always think to myself what a
[ __ ] they said and if I see him then I
sit in first class I torch them with all
the tattoos and bracelets they just look
at me and shake their head get the
dungeon console dog I upgrade on
everything except New York or Chicago
I got an upgrade tonight yeah I got
great I live in them great so I live in
the first class and I tell the guy next
to me I ask him nicely can I get the
I'll if he's a nice guy I let him live
yeah if he's a [ __ ] scumbag I asked
for [ __ ] something no key I'm like
those silent what comes out of my ass if
your big ass oh yeah what are you asking
for last onto no key no like what how do
you determine if he's a good you're not
like to see yeah okay if you're in the
window yeah cuz I don't like the window
gives me anxiety so you're gonna get
[ __ ] bombarded anyway see I love the
window I like I don't want to be in
psychos I get anxiety that again I got a
P more then the guy next to me [ __ ]
falls asleep and I gotta break his balls
all [ __ ] night so I tell him that I
say listen if you don't want to switch
to me and have a hard time cuz I'm gonna
get up 15 [ __ ] times from anxiety to
pee and then if they say no okay I'm
gonna open up this [ __ ] and I'll get
something on the menu that's got some
milk in it and I'll just open up a can
of whoop-ass Adam every time they smell
it yeah what a threat though I'm gonna
open up this ass listen to me the whole
body shake raises right when you [ __ ]
there's an only switch seats with you
men play like ok ok I'll do it
no I'm happy you got it I'll switch my
had about six months ago I had no lady
next to me that was catching like Hara I
went to like Texas or something she was
catching and I the problem is you don't
[ __ ] that morning and you get on a plane
so last two I was in the flight it's
those best [ __ ] though death farts that
come out before you [ __ ] that last
couple of that they real close to your
[ __ ] this poor lady asked her husband
if she could switch when I wake people
up yeah with a fart that is what I know
the beYOU know the best is the best is
when their makeup looks worse when they
get off the plane you know because their
face has been scrunched up the whole
time get that pillow I have woken up
I've heard people like in this sleep
light is choking on it
especially a mint because they have to
wear goggles there was a lady that was I
stood up the fart yeah not this last
trip to Fort Lauderdale the one back
from Boston yeah
if you've got a myth yeah sorry they had
the solo booth oh the two or four the
solo yeah you got two or four or six I
went that was blasted so many farts of
the tube that I couldn't take it like I
was the cube the farts were going low to
the floor
sorry time like I bent over to give the
night father something like it's nothing
it was just a root of the [ __ ] like
six sixes yourself so I open up the door
and there's a lady sleeping next to me
and I can see her she's for hours they
give you those things to put on your
eyes you know that right give you a gift
pack up yeah miss can tooth brush the
whole thing yeah she's got she's playing
the game she's d basically with the
doctor and all of a sudden when I got up
I turn that make believe I'm doing I'm
getting something out of my overhead
compartment yeah but I'm also doing toe
raises cuz I don't want I'm a fat dude I
don't want to get blood clots uh-huh so
what I'm doing all that a fart just
slips out and I'm making believe not
like I don't want to bring it back into
the cubicle yeah so I'm standing in the
hallway crooked in my cubicle make him
believe I'm pulling something out and
all of a sudden I see it
and he SWAT her nose like it's a fly
right like it started off with like this
just must be a fly she was deep in sleep
and finally Doug she actually like
popped up like the whole fart got her it
like she took a deep breath in his fart
and she took the goggles off and popped
up and looked around and I was like you
smell it too I had to get up I think
it's him
and I sat back down this poor lady sat
there for an hour but the all-time best
I had to be 13 and I took the number one
bus from Jersey City not from North
Bergen to the high school but that bus
originates in Jersey City outside the
methadone clinic when we were kids
people would take the number one busted
Jersey City get methadone drinking and
get back on the bus and we were sitting
towards the back facing him those chairs
where you don't face the front face each
other three people could sit down while
I was faced right opposite him and I had
been farting all morning it's 8:00 in
the morning he's on heroin his head is
down he's got drool from his lip to the
newspapers reading the Daily News and he
just passed down the heroin and I
[ __ ] took my hips and I pulled them
up just like I'm
yeah he was like four feet away and
that's what I was addicted to steak
homes stations every night for dinner
Tuesday comes with American cheese and
alright or french fries what comes out
to stay comes she's not around me it's
just somebody's leg yeah like when you
see an axle on the 405 and somebody
loses a leg eh he calls [ __ ] steak
steak comes they get a couple of Arby's
no the meat in the can-spam man damn
they all got a call this and I got a
black leg it's fresh weight about 600 so
you got like [ __ ] 20 cans of spam I'm
Colin white castle next so they call
spam White Castle and like Wendy's and
they go we got this dead leg where do we
send it to and stake them so dog I've
blasted one of those steaks and farts
yeah I'm like positioning my hips laying
back in the seat and it hit the chant
you could hear it just okay and I just
went right through his nose and he was
past that one he just went like he just
opened his eyes and he won't make this
thing's like what like an adrenaline
Shia Greg Garcia you do it again my
brother can grab this is your what your
19th year in television in a row 25 I
think screams yeah and you ever think
that this would be this way no no I had
no idea and yeah and and then when I
started working you know you don't know
how long you're gonna work either so now
you just consider yourself lucky every
day we've all been here 20 years it's
[ __ ] it's crazy
it's really [ __ ] crazy man absolutely
insane I can't believe it like I still
cannot believe it
I look at that Tommy star lineup that
you sent to me every now and then I
don't send it to you you sent it to me
Kevin Carter
puts it out Darren Carter's got that one
I mean you Dave Chappelle closes silly
McCullough's I'm sowwy McCullough this
it's just I sit there and people have no
idea I came to this town I got a web
mike yeah let's just see what happened
yeah let's just see what happens I got
into the economy store and I just never
left
was like a bug on the wall it's so crazy
how you're ended yeah you're with it
yeah I think all of us just came I was
just like we didn't know anybody
mm-hmm like let's just give this a try
you ever have a conversation with
something you last 20 years that you
left and said I can't believe I was just
almost that person all the time like I
can't believe ya just thought of that
person like I just saw him on this still
happens to me me too yeah especially but
somebody watch growing up yeah just
crazy I'm buddies with the guy did you
watch those uh
HR puffs and stuff and Land of the Lost
and these things and Marty Krofft yeah
yeah there's a dude that I've become
buddies with Marty Krofft it's just
amazing to me I just watch those shows
non-stop when I was a kid and it's not
Pufnstuf yeah so like you didn't you get
a smoky in the Bandit car I did yeah got
a smoke in the Bandit car and and I got
it signed by Burt Reynolds yeah and then
the car wash guy washed it off oh yeah
that's how you would tell me yes right
well the burr trail yeah that's right
exactly yeah yeah got it scrubbed up and
he was gonna resign it in October you
know what like he went when he died I
went back and looked at all the movies
he made he was in the 70s was a [ __ ] in
the dude oh yeah but in like a true
movie star movie star movie stuff more
like you know like they I don't know
that they have movie stars like he was
now it was do you know what I mean like
everybody's so accessible now the
difference between the stars then and
the stars now is that they enact
Nicholson never made him self super
accessible they've removed themselves
from the regular people do you know I
mean it's crazy which gave them some
like mystery there's no mystery to
anybody I'm not here to put anybody down
but like when the guy won the Oscar for
The Hurt Locker 30 years ago that guy
wouldn't be invited to a room Steve
McQueen what a punch the [ __ ] that's the
way it is you know yeah Steve McQueen
and Bronson would have knocked the [ __ ]
out of met
and his little buddy they would have
ripped his wig off and Tom welcome back
to his [ __ ] studio ever again my kids
these guys were different like when you
were you you know when you were around
Burt Reynolds there was something about
him that you know we were telling a
story I think here when we Burt relavant
to shoot something and if he wants The
Longest Yard this one scene way he
tackles me and I actually go down yeah I
remember coming down going this guy
could still [ __ ] somebody up yeah I
don't get correct he still has two good
punches him yeah like if you watch The
Longest Yard now the original they cut
it out but he slacks that [ __ ] and the
opening of the movie gets in the car
it's it's Saturday night whatever bite
when it's Skynyrd he was truly a man of
the 70s yeah and those stars do not
exist today no the guy that does the
movies with whatever that is done
Deadpool what all that Ryan Reynolds
that's not that's not what I'm talking
about those guys wouldn't even be able
to get beat up they would actually get
beat up yeah they were there was a
different type it was a different time
yeah you know it's funny when I told you
that the one day Steve he told me a
story that Steve McQueen called or Clint
Eastwood called Burt Reynolds to say get
your motorcycle that director died we're
gonna drive out to Vegas and piss on his
grave
cuz they fired Clint Eastwood at clinics
because it doesn't really matter when
you die when I piss on your [ __ ] gray
you know all those type of it's a
different Hollywood yeah it's a time for
in Hollywood you know when they booked
the Magnificent Seven the star was Yul
Brynner and all those guys got together
that are in that movie and said he's not
gonna come from something else I'm far
in it it's not gonna come here and steal
a movie from us so they [ __ ] at him at
that for most of Cafe George see Scott
McLean Charles Bronson would call him up
all night and send them room service at
the hotel it's a different type of
[ __ ] animal yeah
you know now everybody's fake they gotta
be buddy-buddy you got to be politically
correct you really can't say what's on
your mind so these guys don't I would
what's the other one you went to see
that Deadpool but the bug like those
guys on it stars what bug ant-man I got
what that was they just did just after
maybe ten men oh no I don't see a minute
what we judge good acting today gets
eaten alive when I grew up on that scene
that I showed you
that's real acting that was [ __ ]
great that's what really made me want to
watch that yeah yeah yeah till you say
five hours that's for four hours
circulant and then Once Upon a Time in
America went with uh with when they
played noodles yeah people the Jews get
over and then Mario Lansky that's a
five-hour [ __ ] movie once upon a time
the America's four hours of forties in
yeah yeah you didn't tell those people
to cut your movie down in those days I
cut it down what get the [ __ ] out of
here before I smack you you know it was
a different savage that you that's why
did they want marlon brando for The
Godfather
after what he did to them one mutiny on
the bounty
yeah they just sent Marlon Brando down
in and he picked somebody he's like hey
you coming you ever direct before no
you're directly yeah yeah I'm gonna go
[ __ ] this Hawaii on the ps4 next 20
years that's really then yeah and they
wouldn't they like we gave you millions
to shoot a [ __ ] movie then you put a
Hawaiian to shoot the movie and you go
[ __ ] some other chick and then they
bought the island they don't have that
no more no they have to act it out to be
that yeah
there's two there's two I think there's
too much stuff to be that crazy you know
when it was like you know it was like
not a lot of things you could also hide
it a little bit yeah it's harder to hide
crazy now it's really hard to hide crazy
cuz everybody's got a [ __ ] where you
gonna be crazy
everybody's got a camera yeah all the
time all the time way more young yeah
where you gonna be crazy
ah those days a long fun yeah yeah yeah
I mean I dunno some part people who have
parties now who make you leave your
phone in the door that's how you know
it's gonna be a good party yeah
if they don't ask for my phone yeah you
got invited to parties where people ask
you know somebody asked me and leave my
father died for me go [ __ ] yourself yeah
go [ __ ] you and your mother I'm gonna
give my giving you my [ __ ] phone a
[ __ ] to you Greg Garcia always a
pleasure Josh
always a pleasure always the place they
can find your new CD comedian Josh wolf
coms called father of the year and you
on TBS to 23rd the premiere yes uncle
Joey Joey I will remind you people next
Tuesday next Monday to watch it and
that's it and that's that we have a
great week I love your [ __ ] I
want to thank Greg Garcia who has a
[ __ ] Twitter page and who gives away
more money than [ __ ] in you know this
guy gives me way more money than the
[ __ ] Kardashians if you're not
following him you're [ __ ] up and the
other day he had people [ __ ] gambling
giving three numbers like he's killed
but my whole page with Sunday for 470 44
and I retweet it because I love Greg
Garcia laughs because you get every
single guest as well and then I got to
go through all that [ __ ] it's crazy I
love it
I am Joey retweets it forget about it
through you it's the first person to say
the number yeah yeah yeah it's got to be
a tell you have a tie it's got to go to
the first person so then I go through it
I got to figure out sometimes I just put
out there like I think this is the
winner somebody speak up if it's not
like no look at this I had it earlier my
gosh you're the new winner sweet funny
jokes and when Greg Garcia's giving away
money yeah somebody's giving away money
I retweet those [ __ ] if one of
my friends can make a dollar bill I'm
here for you why not why not yeah you
buy on my special I love you guys have a
great week all right I want to thank my
main man Josh wolf always a pleasure I
can't believe I know I'm 20 years I want
to thank Greg Garcia for stopping by but
most importantly I want to thank you
guys for listening for giving us the
opportunity before you go let me talk to
you about something listen watching the
games the baseball playoffs football the
UFC it's fun
but it's a lot more entertaining when
you've got some action on the game so
I'm not encouraging you to bet what I'm
saying is talking about making money by
doing it correctly you guys heard me
talking about this for weeks and now
it's time you [ __ ] sit on the ball
okay whether you're an expert or a
rookie you should be betting in my book
you're like why Joey if you're the kind
of guy like some better little and win a
lot like playing numbers on a rule like
you to create a big parlay you pick
three teams three moves and if you hit
all three of them you could turn 100
into 600 there's so much to bet on
playoff baseball hockey fights college
football football Jesus Christ but my
book is the one you bet I know you'll be
happy with alright I recommend these
guys because I trust them my bookie has
been in business for years they've got
great online reviews and their mobile
site is easy to use
so listen stop sitting there like a Mook
the holidays are two months away
you got Thanksgiving you want to show up
for the turkey or you want to eat
[ __ ] a tofu turkey that's up to you
my bookie will match your first deposit
dollar dollar for dollar but you gotta
join today right now because they're
pulling that off log in to my bookie
right now and WG this use promo code
Church CH you are CH and you'll get your
first deposit match 100% my bookie you
play you win you get paid you understand
me and at the end of the day that's the
most important thing let me ask you a
question you know it's not smart job
sites are overwhelm you with tons of the
wrong resumes but you know what is smart
you guessed it
zip recruiter go to zip recruited calm
slash Church unlike other job sites a
zip recruiter doesn't wait for
candidates to find you
zip recruiter finds them it's a powerful
matching technology that scans thousands
of resumes identifies people with right
skills education and experience for your
job and actively invites them to apply
so you get the best candidates available
qualified and fast
no more sorting through wrong resumes no
more waiting on the right candidates to
apply
it's no wonder zip recruit is rated
number one by employers in the US and
that rating comes from high insights on
trust a lot with
over a thousand reviews and right now
the church family whether you've got a
big business or a small business or a
medium business right now you can try
zip recruiter for free Joey what do you
mean I'm telling you you to try for free
by going to this exclusive address zip
recruiter comm slash Church that zip
recruiter comm slash Church Church
si-hu rch zip recruited comm slash
Church no more waiting and scanning for
these bums you want the right candidate
zip recruiter is the way to go again
free zip recruiter comm slash Church and
let us not forget about investments
Robin Hood is the investing app that
lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options Kryptos or commission free
simple and intuitive clear design with
the data presented and an easier way to
digest ok listen my wife goes on there
she loves Robin Hood I don't know what
she's been doing lately but she loves it
it's easy understand charts and market
data place the trading just for taps on
your smartphone it's that easy
Rob the Robin Hood web platform also
lets you view stock collections one
hundred most popular sectors like
entertainment and social media and
curated categories like female CEOs and
analyst ratings of buy hold and sell for
every stock listen you learned by doing
you learn how to invest as you build
your portfolio you discover those stocks
and track favorite companies with a
personalized news feed what I'm gonna do
is this Robin Hood is giving the church
the family us a free stock like app will
Ford sprint to help build your portfolio
who does that for you nobody uncle Joey
does that for you sign up in church dot
Robin Hood calm you've been thinking
about it for a long time it's time you
pulled the trigger and Robin Hood is
going to give the church a free stock
like Apple for the sprint to help build
your portfolio sign up at church dot
Robin Hood calm
that's church dot robin hood calm listen
I wanna thank Josh welcome I think Greg
Garcia I want to thank Michael Bisping
Louis J Gomez I want to thank the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys for being part of the church family
do not forget I want to also give a
special shout out to roots of fight they
always send me great stuff
do not forget next Thursday [ __ ]
straight-up [ __ ] hilarities in
Cleveland and then 11:8 Kate Quigley and
myself invade the New York City Comedy
Festival i Gotham tickets are cheap
Thursday night Friday night - show
Saturday night - shows so you got
hilarities 1125 through 1120 setup on a
ten twenty five through ten twenty seven
which is October then you got New York
got them who gives a [ __ ] about New
Year's Gotham I see you [ __ ] at
hilarities in Cleveland alright have a
great week
have a great weekend god bless you
[ __ ] I love you and I'll see
you guys bright and early Tuesday
morning Monday morning I'll see you guys
all right stay black have a great
weekend uncle Joey loves you check this
[ __ ] meal Lee